[Música]
en Guatemala cientos de personas
marcharon en la capital para exigir que
se respete el resultado de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones generales
mientras la Corte Suprema dio 10 días
para confirmar el recuento de las actas
en una primera visita Colombia cargada
de simbolismo el presidente de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva unió su voz a
la de Gustavo Petro en defensa de la
amazonía frente a la comunidad
internacional tendremos análisis en
nuestro estudio
la crisis climática y el fenómeno del
niño que calienta las aguas del Pacífico
ponen en riesgo a cientos de especies de
las Islas Galápagos uno de los
ecosistemas más diversos del planeta
Tierra
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
maceo y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
empezamos con información de Guatemala
porque este sábado cientos de personas
marcharon en la capital para exigir que
se respeten los resultados de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones generales del
pasado 25 de junio la oea informó este
sábado que la misión de observación
electoral que ha participado esta semana
en la revisión de las actas no detectó
ninguna irregularidad grave mientras
este viernes la Corte Suprema de
Justicia dio un plazo de 10 días para
confirmar El recuento Bueno
popular que se oficialista en los
resultados y que se respeta la
democracia participativa el pueblo ya
hizo manifestarse en las urnas del
pasado 25 de Julio en otras noticias
este sábado la ciudad colombiana de
Leticia en medio de la selva fue el
escenario de un encuentro de líderes de
ocho países para preparar un gran
acuerdo para proteger la amazonía esto
antes de la Cumbre amazónica de agosto
ahora Contamos con nuestra periodista
Omar Romero salas para analizar el
encuentro mar bienvenida le preguntó Qué
efectos a la práctica puede tener esta
Cumbre si es importante aquí Rosa
destacar que es la primera vez que
efectivamente los ocho países que tienen
jurisdicción sobre la Cuenca amazónica
se reúnen en una Cumbre son casi siete
millones de kilómetros cuadrados de
superficie Y por supuesto este
ecosistema no conoce fronteras Así que
la coordinación pública entre todos
estos países para protegerlo tiene tiene
mucha relevancia Y pues la presencia de
Lula y de Petro por supuesto le da un
peso especial al encuentro especialmente
Porque estos gobiernos han hecho de la
defensa del medio ambiente una de sus
banderas y una de las cosas que los
definen como gobiernos de izquierda en
la región sin luego a pesar de la buena
sintonía que exhibieron Lula y Petro
durante Durante este encuentro puede ser
que haya problemas en lo que concierne a
Perú que es un país que también tiene
que haber consenso entre los tres para
que tenga algo de peso la Cumbre y
sabemos que Petro por ejemplo no
reconoce el gobierno de Dina boluarte
así que bueno Podrían haber tropiezos de
Cara a la Cumbre que se está preparando
ahora no para agosto para inicios de
agosto de este mismo año veremos que
sale de ahí sin embargo Es verdad que es
una de las cumbres que quizás viene con
más planes concretos de los gobiernos
por ejemplo la propuesta de Petro de
intercambiar deuda externa por
protección del medio ambiente Mary le
pregunto precisamente que han hecho
Petro y Lula en Colombia y en Brasil
concretamente desde que llegaron al
poder sí aunque llevan muy pocos meses
Es verdad que ya han anunciado que se ha
frenado la deforestación el gobierno de
Petro informó que se detuvo en un 76% en
el primer trimestre de 2023 respecto a
2022 y en Brasil también se redujo un
33,6% en este primer semestre de año
Pero esto sólo en dos países la
situación en términos generales sigue
siendo problemática se calcula que
respecto a niveles precolombinos se ha
deforestado un 17% de la amazonía y el
gran responsable el principal el
principal responsable es la ganadería la
actividad humana en lo que respecta a la
ganadería algo que muestra al final que
el cambio para revertir esta
deforestación de la amazonía va a tocar
puntos neurálgicos de las economías de
muchos países requiere muchísimo trabajo
el objetivo es no llegar al 20% de
deforestación que podría ser un punto de
no retorno mar pues muchísimas gracias
por este análisis Gracias a ti nosotros
seguimos con noticias climáticas vamos a
Ecuador porque ahí la crisis climática
sumada a la llegada del fenómeno del
niño pone en riesgo a decenas de
especies salvajes de las Islas Galápagos
marinas sardinha tiene los detalles
con sus afiladas garras y sus gruesas
crestas de espinas dorsales estas
iguanas de las Islas Galápagos parecen
muy resistentes pero son altamente
vulnerables a los cambios de temperatura
y ahora están amenazadas por el fenómeno
del niño esto se traduce en éxito
reproductivo de estas especies si el
éxito reproductivo de estas especies
golpea su condición poblacional estamos
hablando de un fenómeno del niño en el
ámbito Parque Nacional Galápagos en el
ámbito de conservación con un efecto muy
grave las inusuales altas temperaturas
de las aguas del Pacífico pronostican
tiempos difíciles para los reptiles de
las emblemáticas Islas ecuatorianas y el
fenómeno del niño podría acabar con el
medio de subsistencia de estas iguanas
un tipo de algas marinas que se
encuentran en aguas poco profundas el
principal alimento de las 450.000
iguanas de La Isla el simple cambio en
la temperatura del mar hace que el alga
desaparezca y el alga es el principio de
la cadena trófica para todos los demás
animales del mar Pero principalmente
marihuana que es un es un reptil grande
los expertos climáticos dicen que el
niño trae consigo un clima más extremo
en América Latina afectando al
equilibrio de la fauna y flora de estos
delicados ecosistemas el fenómeno
también trae lluvias intensas al
Pacífico que pone en riesgo la
reproducción de estas tortugas si esas
lluvias son abundantes en frecuencias en
intensidad sus zonas de Nido pudieran
inundarse y si se inundan va a afectar
la reproducción de los nidos
posiblemente a cero el turístico
archipiélago es patrimonio de la
humanidad pero la crisis climática
podría ser el fin de unas especies que
no se encuentran en ningún otro lugar
del mundo cambiamos de tema la crisis
económica en Argentina ha provocado que
el país se convierta en un atractivo
comercial para los habitantes
fronterizos de Naciones vecinas como
Uruguay
cientos de uruguayos aprovechan la
crisis económica Argentina largas filas
de automovilistas Se forman en El Paso
fronterizo entre ambas naciones el
objetivo es llegar a la localidad
Argentina de gualeguaychú para hacer la
despensa tomar gasolina cortarse el pelo
y comprar otros artículos por mucho
menos de lo que gastarían en Uruguay con
lo mismo acá rinden el doble se pueden
dar un lujo de salir a comer que en
Uruguay no no todo el empleado común no
lo puede hacer el cambio de Divisas en
gualeguaychú favorece a los uruguayos
con 100 dólares fuimos al cambio y nos
dieron 48.000 argentinos que con eso acá
compramos ropa nos hacemos el pelo la
nafta comemos argentina se enfrenta a
una inflación de casi el 100% en el
valor de su moneda lo que merma el poder
adquisitivo de los locales pero que
hacer el país sudamericano un destino
Muy atractivo para sus vecinos sin
embargo de vuelta en Fray bentos en el
lado uruguayo las autoridades locales
reportan que en lo que va del año más de
170 comercios locales han cerrado En
consecuencia de la desbandada de
clientes atraídos por los bajos precios
al otro lado de la frontera con esos
chicos que se han cerrado después así
este los grandes también que va a hacer
o cómo cambiar han sacado personal para
mitigar el efecto las autoridades
aduaneras uruguayas han limitado el paso
de mercancía proveniente del lado
argentino a 5 kilos y cerramos con
deportes porque quedan ya pocos días
para el inicio del mundial de fútbol
femenino de Australia y de Nueva Zelanda
un torneo en el que la selección
brasileña es una de las favoritas de
América Latina mientras en Brasil para
muchas jóvenes el fútbol se ha
convertido en una salida para escapar de
distintos tipos de violencia
en su fondo de pantalla su gran ídola
karine de 17 años sueña con seguir los
pasos de Marta una leyenda del fútbol en
Brasil
he tenido este sueño desde que era
pequeña porque he jugado desde entonces
este sueño me acompaña y creo que podré
hacerlo hasta entonces es un proceso y
lo respetaré Tengo este sueño de ser
futbolista
los rincones de su casa ubicada en un
complejo de favelas en Río de Janeiro
delatan su aficionado al deporte una que
comparte con su madre que no pudo
hacerlo su profesión debido a las
enormes brechas que recaen sobre el
fútbol femenino el fútbol representa a
todos sufrimos prejuicios porque siempre
dicen que el fútbol no es para mujeres
es para hombres como karine son muchas
las jóvenes que se han acercado al
fútbol en las favelas de Brasil un
deporte que según los organizadores del
proyecto cara a cara ha servido para
alejar a las menores de edad de
diferentes tipos de violencia
la posibilidad de hacer cosas malas
especialmente en la comunidad de la
Favela Es abrumadora somos una
oportunidad más para que hagan el bien
en la comunidad que no se fijen solo en
las cosas malas sino que tengan un
camino correcto
el proyecto promueve torneos como la
Favela cop y Espera que de ahí surjan
las nuevas generaciones que releven a la
selección que en pocos días representará
a Brasil en el mundial de Australia y
Nueva Zelanda hasta aquí las noticias
gracias por su atención
[Música]